your message to artists don't quit your
day job yes
so it's so important because it goes
back to what we were saying about having
your your a goal and your B goal and by
you having a day job for me anyways it
gave me the stability to create my own
films right I was able to procure
locations feed casts take care of them
do films do projects because I had a day
job
if I only worried about booking jobs
to live I would be struggling because I
haven't booked a job in this field in
like five six years
so then that means I would go five or
six years without any income looking to
work as a PA on set or you know having
to do background work or having to do
Oddball jobs whereas when you agree when
you get that skill
you're able to just build the foundation
and without the foundation you can't do
anything
but with the foundation of uh Financial
Security and it doesn't matter how much
you make
thirty thousand fifty thousand eighty
thousand you know how much you're
bringing in so you can kind of mold your
life around it
then you're able to create you're able
to know okay I'm off Friday Saturday
Sunday I'm gonna film Fridays and
Saturday nights or Saturdays and Sun
however you're going to do it and I'm
just going to do that slowly
consistency for a Creator is more
important than anything so if you're a
writer I have a goal that I live by
if I'm planning on writing a script
because I like a story I do a minimum of
three pages a day
and that minimum means if I can get
three pages a day then in a month I have
a script
if you do one page a day and you hold
yourself to that one page in three
months you'll have a script but if
you're not disciplined enough to hold
yourself to that one page or three pages
then you'll never have anything and that
story will stay stuck in your head
so when you have discipline you have
your your goal a goal B it becomes so
important because you're able to get a
lot further think about it if you go to
the gym and you're disciplined to work
out every day you're going to get
stronger so if you're a filmmaker and
you're disciplined to shoot every
weekend
discipline discipline okay maybe it took
you six months but now in six months
compared to you thinking about doing
something it's done
that Turtle verse the race uh that
turtle versus the rabbit that we all
used to listen to and how the turtle
used to win
you don't understand it as a kid or when
you're younger because you're like the
rabbit is way faster
but consistency can move mountains
so be consistent
okay let me just play the opposite
approach for a minute though let's
suppose you get this great job I.T it's
very in demand especially now post
pandemic
what if you get into a lifestyle now you
have a nice car now you have a nice
place now you have friends coming over
for dinner and they're in the same
profession or or similar and and then
there's this little gnawing at you and
you're like you know what I don't want
to be at this keyboard right now I want
to be creating something I had that
and that's what led me to making films
once you
get that creative bug
kind of never leaves you because even
though I kind of quit Hollywood I didn't
stop
that feeling never left me of wanting to
create and wanting to see something
so lifestyle working in the job you
can't make the excuses
if you want to do it you have to find
time right and I say that because I'm
married I still have time for my wife
I'm a father I still have time for my
son we do his Kumon and his schoolwork
and I pick him up from the bus stop
I still work 40 hours a week at my job
when I get off at five
I can either write a script from five to
six I can edit a film from five to six
that consistency as a turtle
every day of one hour two hours of
creative output
leads to a mountain of work
in three years
from an independent standpoint
you have three films
you have a web series with 12 to 13
episodes
you have a reality show about a med spa
and then you have a reality pilot
episode
in three years
and you're only able to do that if
you're consistently pounding at it so
even if you're in a career instead of
mindlessly searching through social
media and letting an hour pass by
you can go and align that effort towards
what it is that you're trying to
accomplish
so again if you're trying to write a
script or you're trying to write a book
do a page a day because in three months
your script is done
if you're shooting a film
shoot one day a week
and then before you know it if it's 16
days okay in four months you're done
shooting and now you're in post and then
you apply that same tactic go edit for
an hour
go edit on the weekend
it's all about balance and consistency
because you still need time for your
friends you still need time for your
spouse or significant other you still
need time for your kids you need time
for yourself
I do all that while I still play video
games right it's important to have that
balance but if you are a creative and I
think someone gave me this statistic I
think like 12 percent of the world are
creatives
and then 98 of filmmakers never make a
second film right those two kind of
Statistics I think are accurate but I
could be wrong if 12 of the world are
creatives then that and the whole world
consumes art right every film is Art
every commercial every story is art
then that means if you're one of those
creatives and that kind of sticks with
you and that's like the invisible Wings
on your back that that you just have to
fly
then you owe it to yourself
and you owe it to your to the world
to let that art out because if you die
one day with that art inside of you
and you're old and you're only stuck
with your thoughts
you don't want to live a life or leave a
life with regrets you want to live a
life regardless of the success attached
to it
with I did it I tried my best and I gave
my best effort
the results are out of your hands
because even films with hundreds of
millions of dollars in budget flop
the success is out of your hands the
creation
and given it its best effort
is within your capabilities
so before you leave this earth
do everything that you can to get that
feeling that that conscious art out of
you because if you don't do it in that
web of Consciousness somebody else is
going to pull it
so
for example I wasn't planning on making
pizza boy Rick which is my latest film
that's in post I wasn't planning on
making it at all I was at a Cisco event
as an engineer
for three days in Vegas
and I was laying in bed by myself just
randomly watching TV the thought came to
me instantly the whole story I could see
play in my head
I went into my phone in my notes and I
just wrote points uh Rick goes here okay
this what this is what happens and then
I came back wrote the script in about a
week
if I didn't pull that
from the artistic Consciousness that all
creators I think pull ideas from
somebody else would have
so I think it's important
to give it your best effort
for yourself as a human being and for
your soul
because we all die
and you don't want to be on your
deathbed say man
I wish I would have done things
differently
you think that nine to five gives you
structure where you know you have this
hour before you have to I don't know
pick up your son or take them to Kumon
or whatever and and you're like I have
to do this now or it's not going to
happen
it gives me stability because we would
all love to just make films full time
and be like Spielberg or Christopher
Nolan or Quentin Tarantino we would all
love that we would all want to be in
that position
but until you're in that position
then you have to do
what works
and
what I've realized growing up and going
through life is that life does not have
to be a struggle
when you grow up poor like I did in many
other people in the world you think that
struggle is normal that you have to
struggle
but when you realize that hey if I just
take these steps in life differently
maybe I don't have to struggle well
guess what if you're back to being that
18 year old kid that wants to fly out
because you don't have a stable home and
you want to go and you're just going to
try it and and struggle along the way
unless you get that Lottery lucky break
compared to that same 18 year old that
goes to the military which I had this
conversation with my brother hey go to
the Army four years you get the VA loan
so that means you automatically get
approved for a house you can rent out
that house rent out those rooms stay in
one of the rooms and they pay for your
mortgage you can get one percent down on
a million dollar loan for your business
so you can buy a business that generates
money for you and then you do those few
things outside of them paying for your
degree and going to school while you're
learning and you're a young man now you
come out in four years at 22 with a
degree that's paid for no debt the
ability to get a small business loan and
buy a home that's all provided for you
because you you sacrifice four years or
you gave four years now you took your
life in your own hands and gave yourself
a leg up right because now you have
these options so now you can pursue
whatever it is you want to pursue from a
stable point of view compared to
I'm just going to go out and I'm going
to try and figure it out I'm just going
to try and figure it out like for some
people it works
but when I say life doesn't have to be a
struggle
it doesn't if you just make the right
choices
if you just and someone can say well
what's the right choices right okay so
I'll step back and say if you just make
more calculated choices
I think you can get to your destination
without as much pain
you know it's funny you say that you you
if you had an open schedule if something
an open schedule can sometimes be
detrimental too because now you can put
stuff off because you're your own
Taskmaster so you really have to like
reevaluate once you have that open
schedule to-do list fixes all that sure
so if you have a to-do list
and and you kind of write what you want
to accomplish
you'll be surprised at how fast you can
get that to-do list done if you stick to
because every story starts on a piece of
paper or on your screen you have to
write the words down before you make a
film right
if you have a to-do list and on that
to-do list I have to do laundry I have
to do work I have to write this page for
the script I have to you know take my
son to the dentist
okay
if you just mark it off and you look at
that to-do list
you'll realize how quickly you're able
to get things done but that to-do list
holds you accountable if you're looking
at it now with that open schedule if you
don't have a to-do list
you're fiddling around you're wasting
time for me one of my greatest assets
because I'm not the best director
there's other directors that are better
I'm not the best cinematographer there's
other cinematographers that are better
not the best writer I'm not the best
anything but what I am
are two things
I'm a grinder
I will grind it Non-Stop and knock on
the door Non-Stop
and I I get laser focused
so that laser focus helps out a lot
because when I stick to okay my rule was
three pages a day I tend to write 12 to
15 a day because writers know like once
you start getting in the flow the story
kind of writes itself and kind of goes
and I don't worry about punctuation I
don't worry about spelling correctly
sometimes I don't even worry about
describing a scene I'll say interior uh
house in Alaska
fireplace
Jim walks into the front door the fire
is burning
there is no
the smell of the burning wood
permeates through the building you can
see the smoke as it leaves the front
door Jim walks in the door creaks for
what when I shoot it it's going to
either Creak or it's not going to Creak
when I edit it and I do sound design
it's either I'm going to add it or I'm
not so if you're going to sell it you
need to colorize it but if you're going
to film it then don't get caught up on
making those words sound perfect get
caught up on how do you make the story
that you see in your head out on that
paper and then how can you the best to
your abilities get that shot